millions of americans could be at risk
of eviction
in just two days when federal
protections created during the pandemic
are set to expire
about six and a half million households
were behind on rent earlier this month
and around half of those families and
individuals worry that
they could be evicted in the next two
months that's even though congress has
allocated more than 46 billion dollars
to help americans affected by the
pandemic pay their rent
janet chamleon is in las vegas where
just a fraction of the money for rent
relief has reached those
who need it most janet good morning
anthony good morning to you the rent
relief money is being allocated
differently state by state here in
nevada
they had only given out about three
million dollars by the end of june
texas on the other hand has doled out
some 400 million dollars
but even renters there are worried that
they're not going to get the help they
need
before the deadline the bumpus family
may be on a ramp to homelessness
jeremy says he was laid off in january
and hasn't paid rent in five months
when the moratorium ends saturday he's
worried his family will be evicted
i'm from california so i'm not from here
so i don't really have no backup plan or
no plan b
i don't have family and friends the
owner of their houston area home
has gone to court to get them out what
will it be like
at the end of the month when the
moratorium ends we are absolutely
terrified
of what will happen at the end of the
month once the moratorium ends because
any case that was on hold can no longer
be on hold
juan santa maria of lone star legal aid
says he has
60 more cases just like the bumpuses
protests have erupted across the country
as the eviction crisis has worsened
as many as 15 million people are in the
same situation as the bumpuses
at risk of losing their homes while they
wait
for federal rent relief the bad news is
that the money is getting out
very slowly getting the money quickly
this week diane yentl of the national
low-income housing coalition
offered congress a startling fact in
some places it's not getting out at
all and it will not reach all the
renters who need it to stay stably
housed in time
nearly half the states in the country
have used less than five percent of
their federal relief money
as of june florida south carolina and
new york
had given out less than one percent but
the money has been flowing faster
recently
deputy treasury secretary wali adayama
acknowledged that early rules
like allowing only landlords to apply
for relief
slowed down distribution we revised the
rule to make sure
that tenants individual people can
actually apply for that money
in addition to doing that we've
simplified the application process
and we've offered local communities and
states the opportunity to work with them
to make sure that we can improve the
ways that they get the money out the
door
and i really don't think we're going to
see this big wave of pending evictions
if anything else i think it's going to
cause people to really
incentivize that communication between
renter and property owner
john boryak owns these lower income
apartments in houston
and heads up an association of area
property owners
he believes the moratorium should not be
extended saying it's taken an especially
hard hit on so-called mom and pop owners
with only a handful of properties this
is their livelihood and so when those
rents go unpaid the mortgage is still
due and the utility bills are still due
advocates like santa maria say rent
relief programs
are working but require patience it's
understandable if you haven't been paid
in four
or five months you're not thinking the
six month or the seventh month
that's when you're going to get paid
these programs are successful it just
takes a little bit of time
king queen but the clock is ticking as
millions struggle to keep a roof
over their heads in some cases states
simply don't have the staff to run such
a large organization but there are signs
of improvement
in june the states gave out more money
than the in the previous five months
combined
anthony janna thank you